it is a 58 billion dollar industry and
we're talking about weight loss and
there truly is a right way to shed some
of those extra pounds and here to tell
us more is personal trainer daniel
magyar hi daniel all right thank you
very much for having me welcome you've
got some great information when it comes
to weight loss and a lot of times when
people want to lose weight the first
thing
that they really recommend that you look
at is hormones exactly so
what i always do in my practice i always
recommend my clients to check their
hormones first because the last thing
you want to do is work very hard diet
very hard and not get the proper results
for it so i recommend checking
testosterone your estrogen your
prolactin ph tsh levels and make sure
that they're in optimal ranges before
you start your journey it's because it's
going to be different for every person
right well it is very difficult for a
man to burn fat if the estrogen is high
okay so that needs to be taken care of
before starting the journey and what
about for women where do you find as far
as hormones go the biggest also optimal
ranges okay gotcha let's talk about
working hard and exercise
what is is there a a magic pill so to
speak when it comes to exercise what's
the best way to train so every
transformation i've ever approached
is the best when there was exercise
included okay because the exercise that
brings the muscle up that tightens up
the body brings the shapes to women it
doesn't bring any masculine shapes it
makes them more feminine and it
stimulates the hormone when you use the
equipment like we use it's the in-home
training system called h3 which is the
special special system that um includes
the resistance bands in a bar in a
platform now that system helps you
stimulate a little bit more growth
hormones
so you burn fat quicker but it really is
about like resistance training that
really is your best bet isn't it yes so
you truly need heavy loads and absolute
fatigue to deliver muscle muscular
stimulus because there's
if the body doesn't get an absolute
fatigue it doesn't have a reason to
adapt what about diet that's obviously a
big part too absolutely what do you
recommend there so first of all the diet
has to be in harmony with the person you
can't really put yourself on a train
that you can't handle
so make sure that everything about the
diet that you're about to do is going to
be in harmony with you so i personally
use a four high calorie days and three
low calorie days um to start with before
before i start the person on a fat loss
journey
and the reason is because i want to keep
the metabolism firing at the highest
rate
and i drop down to a deficit three days
a week and that creates the downturn and
a fat burn makes sense yeah it makes
complete sense and you actually have the
photos to back it up let's take a look
at some of your clients i mean look at
that transformation that is absolutely
incredible wow wow absolutely amazing
and it's just a matter of months and and
if people want to reach out to you to
get more information how do they do that
instagram okay what is your instagram dm
underscore trainer dm underscore trainer
and you too can have a transformation
like that with just some simple steps
and changes thank you so much thank you
for watching daniel for sponsoring this
segment now he is offering 10 off of his
online coaching program just head to his
instagram again dm underscore trainer
for more information
all right let's check